the Joe Rogan experience yeah I lick it
I give it my herpes Wow
I don't have herpes yet Joe Rogan are
you do it's okay and honestly if you
have it it's fine I'm gonna have a
vaccination
they must have one already thank God
sure what do you think conspiracy
theorists cuz he already sparked up when
we talked about the aliens thing with oh
did he bring up Ohio
no I left it all out there's just
something there's a spark they have
conspiracies yeah they have a little
spark in their eye when they he perked
up he killed his [ __ ] a little bit
when I brought it up yeah but I it was
really funny like those the last
question I asked him was about UFO it
just kind of almost has a joke yeah just
just as a goodbye yeah I like to keep it
silly
that's all I'm reading it's in [ __ ]
hundreds of articles it's all Bernie
Sanders says he will tell the world
about aliens if he becomes president
that's the thing that they took out of
that well it's smart of him it feels
like Trump straws it's like smart if
Bernie had said it if Bernie had brought
it up I would have been like that is a
brilliant tactic but don't you think the
people that believe in aliens are
already going to vote for or that are
the most hung up on it no no you don't
think they're the same no no I think
they were they very wildly conspiracy
theorists or left-wing right-wing and
the alien one is different than any
other one and I think there's a lot more
people that are that are alien lovers
that cross both sides I think it's just
one of those things where you like alley
lovers guys that [ __ ] aliens oh not this
I'll only say lemurs you're holding out
to be build Manhattan yeah do people
claim that I bet you they do not for
sure do you know there's people really
into Bigfoot sexually there's like all
these novels written about Bigfoot just
go date a tall Armenian no no not that
hard they ever go to Glendale everywhere
go to the Galleria there's this Bigfoot
this is a very localized reference
there's Bigfoot you want a Bigfoot or
eyes you get it Bigfoot erotica yeah I
mean it's like really common what if you
had a small deck like you always hear
about the really tall
guys with the tiny dicks and when I say
hear about them you hear about this look
at this seduced by Bigfoot oh look it
come for Bigfoot
Virginia wait big fairies by Lolita
young
wait a minute narrated I mean this is an
audio book you know what they say the
bigger the Bigfoot the bigger the error
in the bones what is that
I like a guy with a really hairy dick
you know like you like people say listen
people say they don't like too much hair
and balls I say get it all the way under
the shaft look at this absolutely
boffing Bigfoot what is happening names
Anna wait wait wait gay Bigfoot look at
this last row and I'll probe what is gay
Bigfoot look he's smoking I'm sorry
after he [ __ ] look at that what the
[ __ ] I'm mouth full of Sasquatch I think
I've met that man it was like one of the
door guys at the Communists that's one
of the what door guys I got fired this
is a whole genre of erotica there's a
bunch of women that write these books
this is Virginia Wade lady is uh she's
apparently very prolific with her
Bigfoot erotica she write he's quite a
few of these how many does she have that
was 13 at least 13 come for Bigfoot come
for Bigfoot number 13 just make [ __ ] up
then there I was walking the dog and the
dog had a heart attack and next thing
Bigfoot's dick is in my mouth I have a
good pun
Harry and the Hummer syns Henderson and
don't see Harry on the think it out loud
and then just I was sounding it out I
can't read come on [ __ ] smart so
there's at least 13 books
I bet Virginia Wade lives in a [ __ ]
giant mansion drives around on a roll
six l ron hubbard oh it's probably a
dude no it's a but I guess I bet it's
with that Bigfoot five baby come for a
Bigfoot baby what is that see that one
come for a Bigfoot five baby why does it
say baby see that see more right hand
side all the way to right all the way
the right all the way the right up above
it there you go BAM what is that [ __ ] is
that
maybe they have a Bigfoot baby it looks
like a come inside or one so she's got
let's find out goose
Google Virginia Wade's big is that her
right there she looks normal might have
been is that a photo of her oh the
goddess go back go back
it was a different book they're talking
okay at the ball for Bigfoot is that her
big was that Virginia Wade that's a
normal looking lady that might not be Oh
Amazon pulls buffed yeah by Bigfoot
romance novels from shelves what why are
they censoring Bigfoot porn yeah that
it's not look at the might have been her
gif okay why don't why didn't anyone
tell me about these literary treasures
oh my god I thought for a second too
long but interesting read was about the
book
this is a long but interesting read why
are they pulling it why are they pulling
this stay-at-home mother from Colorado
of course she is
no real riding experience and so of
course not you don't even have to be
good I mean she spent all day waxing her
nipples she was couldn't get to come to
terms with her hairy body and then she
realized all she needed was to find her
match she says I give this crazy idea
for a story so she sat down and wrote
the entire book in an hour
there's no [ __ ] there's no second
draft that's what I love to hear by my
for my authors you wrote this all in one
draft
she said just 12,000 words in a matter
of weeks she's been considered trying to
sell it to mainstream publisher instead
she went directly to Amazon's Kindle
direct publishing an online platform for
self-publishing 70 percent royalty rate
for authors I think she sold a [ __ ] load
yeah he'll go viral here's the line from
it I don't think he's monogamous
well it's Bigfoot now so big click on
that Bigfoot insider monster porn Amazon
crack down link so let's find out what
the [ __ ] is going on here why would they
crack down on that Oh ad blocker you son
of a [ __ ] okay what's it did so uh
author Virginia Wade's fiction debut
follows a group of women and embark on a
week-long camping trip to Mount Hood
National Forest they are in the shadow
of Oregon's highest mountains their
their kidnapped and sexually assaulted
posterior using creature what the hell
is that thing
asked one protagonist that's some kid
writing it's [ __ ] Bigfoot his shell
II he's real for [ __ ] sake Harve
filled her eyes with a huge see -
- - I'm saying that says [ __ ] corn in
the book his feet are [ __ ] out with
decidedly untitled like come for
Bigfoot's II um of course it's just the
first of sixteen fiction ebooks Wade
a pen name has written about the
legendary but sometimes best sometimes
known as Sasquatch each legendary beast
each detailing a series of graphic and
often violent sexual encounters between
the ape-like creature and a female
lovers okay wait wait has made an
exceptional living writing these stories
Wow
okay but why they take him down this
reminds me of my friend from Middle
School's boyfriend who is Sicilian he
was just so hairy and he looked been
downloaded more than a hundred thousand
times holy [ __ ] that that's five bucks
that means she made five hundred
thousand dollars for one hour work what
she made seventy percent of it at least
do you think I bet you that other books
didn't take as long either Wow during
her best months she's netting thirty
thousand or more in a month
writing Big Foot jerk-off books Wow
taken by pirates
oh she right she branched off in utter
genres it's all just getting [ __ ]
taken by pirates seduced by the Dark
Lord it's like getting [ __ ] by demons
and pirates and hilarious I'm getting
traumatized a traumatic thing is coming
up for me right now
it's weird do you want to hear it what
my mom wrote romance novels when I was
shut the [ __ ] yeah they went
did you ever never published no I didn't
read them they were never published so
it was really just a [ __ ] journal you
read your mom's [ __ ] journal I didn't
read it but she had romance novels
around and I would definitely knew I was
really good at skimming to the sex
scenes I know how to flip through it so
like my Dean to it so your mom wrote she
was a part of this thing called Romance
Writers of America and Chuck she won
awards and then she never followed
through so she could have published the
book and probably at success and then
she had a hole it was like a whole
suspense romance Selena's revenge was
what was called like
you know but that's really funny she
came back it's a fuzz Bigfoot no she
[ __ ] the girl killed her
makes Rita oh yeah